i'm very keen to find out a bit more
about your pitch a bit more about
yourself introduce yourself to our
viewers as well but just first to kind
of talk a little bit about the man who
is leaving at the door of number 10. do
you think boris johnson was a good prime
minister look i think boris johnson
delivered many things for this country
but what we now need to do is we need a
clean start because the reality is we
need the government and the conservative
party to return to the service of the
people and to actually have that clean
start that we all know is needed you'll
remember the first time you interviewed
me
i was in india laying a wreath for
armistice day in delhi
and we spoke then about the fact that
duty and service are fundamental ethos
in this country and that's what i hope
to bring to darling street uh okay um
you say you want to replace boris
johnson
but you've never served in government in
any role
what makes you think you've got the
experience to do this job it's not an
entry level position it's not an
entry-level position but it's not a
management position either it's a
leadership position and the reality is
my entire career has been about serving
our country and leading in combat
operations in iraq and afghanistan in
leading in the foreign affairs domain
where as you know i very clearly stood
up for our country defending our country
against chinese economic threats and
against russian
as you know bullying in many different
areas and that has led to me being
sanctioned by one and quite viciously
attacked by the other and indeed as you
know
i've fought for my country
i've been attacked there too so you know
this is about leading teams it's about
setting out a vision and a clear plan
and that's why i want a 10-year economic
plan for growth i'm keen to talk to you
about the plan and also about some of
your kind of background in the military
i think anyone would suggest that that's
not important experience to have but is
it relevant experience for the top job
you know you have to know what levers to
pull in whitehall it's about leadership
but it's also about getting things done
have you got the experience for that
it's certainly true that it's about
understanding whitehall and if you want
somebody who's understood whitehall i've
literally worked in the
heart of it in terms of helping to run
the defense force of the united kingdom
with general the lord richards and
making sure that we were actually able
to deliver the kind of defence forces
that britain needed in 2015 well 2010 to
2013. and so what we really need to see
now is a clean start what we need is
that return to service to make sure that
the government and the conservative
party are delivering for britain jeremy
hunt says in the telegraph this morning
i'm the only major candidate who hasn't
served in boris johnson's government is
a bit of a dick at you isn't it well
jeremy will express himself as he wishes
and you know jeremy's saying you're not
a major candidate jeremy's record stands
for itself but my record of service
stands for itself too i am extremely
proud of the service i've given to our
country i'm extremely proud to have
fought side by side with some of the
bravest people in this country and i'm
extremely proud of the political
positions i've taken not just on foreign
affairs but at domestic affairs so for
you and i have spoken in the past about
child protection and the way i
championed and led tony have you got
have you got the numbers of course i've
got the numbers that's exactly what
we've been building up because we've
been talking to people around the
conservative party to make sure that we
have the support i wouldn't be doing
this otherwise and we are absolutely
committed to a clean start for the
united kingdom a clean start for the
conservative party and that's exactly
what we're going to deliver let's talk
about that clean start then shall we
should taxes come down
i've always been a low tax conservative
i'm delighted that others are following
i didn't vote for the national insurance
rights and others are now joining me on
that platform and i'm very pleased to
see it because what we need is not a tax
on growth but a growing economy that's
why i keep talking about a clean start
and a 10-year plan for growth that
delivers an economy that is stronger
that is more resilient and most
importantly that is fairer so
specifically on tax cuts then let's talk
about where you would cut taxes if you
say you're a low tax conservative uh
reverse international insurance
corporation tax what would you look at
well i've already set out two so i'm not
going to go into too much detail now
that's why i'm talking about a 10-year
economic plan and we need that cleaning
so what are the two cats
well the two i've already spoken about
of course the national insurance rise
that i didn't vote for and i think i'm
on record and very clearly on the uh on
on the vote as not having supported that
and i've already spoken when i was in
doncaster the other day talking to the
northern research group of conservatives
i was talking about fuel tax because
fuel tax is just crippling so many of us
so how much would those cutting those
two taxes cost well at the moment the
the reality is that the national
insurance
contributions is a 12 billion pound tax
on working people so what we need to do
is to make sure it costs 12 billion
pounds to reverse that that's why we
need to grow the economy that's why you
need a 10-year economic plan because you
can't simply look at each of these taxes
as a one-off you need to look at it as
part of a whole the reality is this
economy needs not only lower taxes for
growth but it also needs sound money and
that's why we need to deliver both
that's why i'm talking about a 10-year
economic plan that delivers a fairer
more resilient and a stronger economy
would you cut corporation tax i'd
certainly be looking at it because the
reality is that what has been set out by
some people today is a 30 billion pound
tax cut as you know down to 15 percent
i'm talking about jeremy hunt and such a
javed i'm just talking about some other
people who've set out a different vision
or rather another vision and what i'm
absolutely clear about is you must look
at all of this but you can only do it in
a balanced way what you need is a clean
start if you get a clean start what you
get is the ability to look again at the
economy and to set out a 10-year
economic plan the reason that's a
stronger a fairer and more resilient the
reason i'm keen to talk about tax cuts
is it feels like everybody is promising
the earth on tax cuts now frankly and
obviously this does come with a cost do
you think that the policies set out on
corporation tax this morning are
actually realistic then no well
they're not realistic unless you have a
10-year economic plan the reality is you
can't simply look at taxes as a one-off
or a single year so would you cut
spending then in that case well this is
why i'm coming back to it if you get a
clean start then what you're able to do
is you're able to get a 10-year economic
plan and a 10-year economic plan allows
you to balance across the economy and
across time so that what you actually
get is you get a growing economy a
stronger economy a more resilient
economy it's it's one thing to say
10-year economic plan but i guess unless
you can kind of talk about spending cuts
or increasing borrowing and then you
know we just how are we supposed to
accept this sophia i'm going to be
setting out all of this in coming days
and you don't expect me to set it out
right now because what we're talking
about today is about how we get change
in our country how we get a clean start
for our country how we get a clean start
for the conservative party and how we
deliver for people across the united
kingdom and make sure those fantastic
conservative voices all across the
united kingdom are able to deliver for
the british people and return the
conservative party to service talking
about delivering for people across the
country inflation is obviously really
high time's very tough for people would
you like to see teachers and nurses get
a pay rise in line with inflation what
i'd really like to see is sound money so
that we don't get into a conversation
about chasing inflationary spirals
that's the real danger and i'm afraid
that's where we've got to what we really
need to do is to make sure that we're
out of this loop so what a month so what
on the pay rises then well i'm not going
to get into the detail of it until i've
set out a 10-year economic plan i'm
afraid it it doesn't work to penny pinch
like that or to or to highlight
individual items that's not the way to
set out a growing economy that's not the
way to restart an economy that's not the
way to get a clean start the only way
you get a clean start is if you have a
10-year economic plan and if you
absolutely ruthlessly look at what it is
that makes the economy grow boosting the
economic outcome for everybody and
building in resilience strength and of
course fairness now
you're the son of a high court judge
you're the nephew of a conservative peer
you went to a very expensive school
do you really understand what it's like
for many families right now who'll be
looking you know at their fuel bills
they'll be looking at the supermarket
bills they'll be looking at their wage
packets they'll be thinking
this isn't going to work
so i've looked off my salary
as a
lieutenant captain a major
in the army
for my whole career
i'm now relatively well paid that's true
but the greatest advantage i've had in
life
the most
remarkable achievement that i've been
able to inherit is that of a loving and
strong family and i have to say that is
the thing that has been
the most determined to my future and i
have to say i know that because i've
seen it for others tony hudgell was a
poor child
who was brutally brutally injured by his
birth parents six or so years ago and
when his real parents those who love him
brought him to see me
paula and mark showed me
the failure of our system and
demonstrated to me also the strength
that a real family can give
and what they did
was they led
an extraordinary campaign
to me
and i then led it through parliament to
deliver for them a change in the law
tony's law to protect children to
protect the most vulnerable what that
demonstrates to me time and again is the
duty of politicians is to serve
and the reality of the strength of a
strong family is supporting even the
most vulnerable
is that something that you want to take
on then
of course it is families come in all
shapes and sizes but the support and
love that families and communities give
is absolutely essential you only get the
service to each other the duty to each
other if you have a community and a
family that works together in whatever
shape it may come
um a couple more um policy areas that
i'm keen to talk to you about before we
like find out a bit more about yourself
as a candidate you voted to remain in
the eu of course do you regret that vote
it's always important when there's a
vote to respect the outcome and i have
always respected the outcome of every
vote what this has done
is it has changed our country it has
caused a revolution in many areas but a
revolution that hasn't yet delivered so
what i want to do is i want to get a
clean start on these
six-year-old arguments that we've been
having i want to get a clean start for
our country i want to get a clean start
from all of these old debates and move
on because the reality is we can look at
the past if you like but the future for
this country is amazing
if there was a referendum tomorrow then
how would you vote there is no way back
into the european union i would never
vote to go back into the european union
that is a very different european union
today and that's over you said um this
week that the full advantages of brexit
are yet to be unleashed
what are the full advantages of brexit
in your view well the full advantages of
brexit are going to come when you have a
clean break clean start and a return to
service because the answer is i just
don't really understand what that what
that means i'm coming to it soon so
if you manage to get a clean start if
you actually get out of the
the the the psycho drama that we've been
in for the last
few years what you're able to do is
you're able to pull this country
together look i can point to communities
like newcastle and durham that are
demonstrating the extraordinary growth
of tech industries that have been
constrained i can point to you if you
like to the economic opportunities of
southeast asia and the different ways in
which we can build relationships i can
point to you to the viking parliaments
to ireland and iceland to sweden and
norway not all in the european union and
point to ways we can work together in
different ways and that's what i've been
working on that's exactly the new kind
of alliances we've been building on but
you can only get them if you get a clean
start because we can't be going around
this boy again and again you say there's
been a psycho drama over brexit recently
what do you mean i mean in the
government look we've been watching the
news as we've been watching you telling
the news uh on uh the recent coverage
and it's very difficult to see anything
other than that so there's been psycho
drama in government you think honda
boris johnson never brexit i think i
think there's been a huge
turmoil in our administration over the
last few weeks and months and i think
you've seen it and you've reported and
that's exactly why we need a clean start
how did you vote in the confidence
motion
i'm not going to talk about that and the
reason i'm not going to talk about it is
because if i go public then it forces
others to go public and that may change
the way people vote okay um on brexit
still the government of course say the
brexit deal that they signed isn't
working in northern ireland so they've
obviously introduced the northern
ireland protocol bill to unilaterally
override parts of that agreement now the
eu says that that breaks international
law
did you vote to support the northern
ireland protocol bill i happen to have
been in america actually representing
our country and our parliament
in negotiations like united states
it was booked several months ago so i'm
afraid
the timing of problems do you support
the protocol bill then i think we need
to deliver it the reality is what we
need is we need two things in order to
change things
you would go let me just finish this
and i'll explain it to you because
you're absolutely right to ask me about
it
i would deliver it and the reason i
would deliver it is because you need two
things to keep the united kingdom's
sovereignty intact and whole
including northern ireland of course
absolutely fundamental to our united
kingdom what you need is you need to
have the leverage and you need to have
the trust the northern ireland bill
delivers leverage but that's not enough
you need a clean start in order to get
the trust in order to get this
government serving the british people
across not just great britain but
northern ireland too and so you would
the eu thinks that it breaks
international law you but you'd be
prepared to have that battle
that's i have fought for my country in
combat i have fought for my country in
parliament and i will keep fighting for
my country okay do you think defense
spending should increase
i think we need to look very hard at
defence spending but what we need is a
clean start in the way we're structuring
our defence forces the reality is we are
structured in many ways for a different
past what we actually need to be doing
is looking at the future and if you look
at the way technology has changed if you
look at the way structures have changed
what we need is a clean start a
revolution in military thinking and then
we're going to have the forces that we
need ready to serve returning to serve
the british people okay um you've called
for a firm response i think it's fair to
say uh towards russia over ukraine um i
just want to have a look at something
you said in february this year in a
debate you said given that a hostile
state has launched an act of war we can
act now we can freeze russian assets in
this country all of them we can expel
russian citizens all of them
surely you don't me didn't mean that
you could expel all russian citizens
from the united kingdom sophie i've
always been very clear as you know about
freezing rushing russian assets in this
country i've called out the dirty money
running through our system since 2018.
i've been absolutely clear that we need
a clean start to clean up not just uh
russian money here but expelling every
russian city what we need what we also
need to do is we need to recognize that
this country must take actions to defend
itself but also to protect those who are
vulnerable there are russian citizens
here who absolutely deserve and require
the protection of the british state
against the tyrant in moscow what we
absolutely need to do as well though is
keep the british people safe and that's
why i have been very clear about
expelling kgb officers those connected
with it and those who are
propagandizing on behalf of a vicious
dictatorship what we really need to be
doing is to be making sure that the
british people are safe and standing up
for our community at the same time
though you know there's one thing saying
to expel people with connections to you
know the russian state but it's another
thing to talk about expelling all
russian citizens i mean it's not a
serious thing for a politician to say is
it it's absolutely serious to stand up
for the british people it's absolutely
clear but to talk about expelling all
russian citizens sophie it is absolutely
essential that you get a clean start on
the relationship
with many european countries but it's
absolutely clear that we don't need a
clean start with russia what we need
with russia is to make a very very clear
statement that what we're willing to do
is to defend ourselves and defend our
community now what we've done so do you
want to expel all russian systems what i
want to do is i want to protect those
russian citizens who are here who are
lawfully here and require protection and
who are absolutely
part of our community i absolutely want
to protect people like that what i also
want to do is to make sure that those
who are a threat those who are
undermining our security and not do not
find sanctuary here okay one more policy
question um
are trans men men and are trans women
women in your view
this is one of those debates
that demonstrates why we need to move on
because
it's really easy
to make division where we need unity
it's really easy
to try and divide communities look
a woman
is an adult human female
but that doesn't mean in any way that
trans women have any less respect or any
fewer rights
and the idea that you can answer this
question with a sledgehammer when really
what you're talking about is a very
subtle understanding of people's rights
people's dignities and the respect we
need for each other i'm afraid it's not
true
we must never take away from human
dignity we must never deny the reality
of what it is to be a biological woman
but we must also respect people who are
in a different
gender identity than their body may have
afforded them and it is a policy
question as well though isn't it and
because we do have single sex provisions
in the country too whether it's
in schools whether it's in
prisons whether it's in sport do you
think they should be protected i
certainly do think they should be
protected
but how they are protected is incredibly
important
what we need is we need to have a clean
start on this debate because actually
this debate is about individuals it's
about people
in cases like prisons in case like
refugees of course there's an answer
which is that women absolutely need to
have a safe space
in cases of sport it's absolutely right
that you recognize the difference in
biology
but it's absolutely right as well that
you recognize human dignity and the
dignity of all people to have equality
okay and i just want to talk about yours
about your story now um
you were wounded twice in afghanistan
during a 10-hour battle in iraq her
doctor even filled out a death notice
view
i read and before you unexpectedly
turned off again
wha what was that like just talk us
through what happened
well it was a
very long night um
i was sent to serve
alongside a extraordinary group of royal
marines i was very proud to be there
and it was an extraordinary time that
taught me a lot about
leadership and
standing together and teamwork but it
mostly taught me actually about our
country
because although
that actually was taken in afghanistan
not in not in iraq but although
although we were a long way from home
i worked with people from
scotland and northern ireland from
across england and across wales
you know it was an extraordinary lesson
for
me of the
wealth and the depth and the strength
and the courage of our country and the
people who make it up it was a fantastic
a fantastic
time for me because of the men that i
served alongside
okay
um i just want to end with a quick fire
round
uh so
let's crack on shall we
who's your biggest rival in this contest
oh i think there are many excellent
candidates sophie and you wouldn't
expect me to answer oh well i would have
doesn't the reason i'm asking because i
was hoping for an answer
look i don't know it's too early to tell
is the honest answer uh we're going to
see i mean you haven't interviewed them
all yet so i'll have to wait and see how
they do with you okay would boris
johnson get a job in your cabinet i
don't think boris johnson would want to
drop in in any future cabinet i think
he's making indications that he's
looking for other things have you done
drugs uh no
what's the naughtiest thing you've ever
done
well i invaded a country once
what's your biggest parenting fail i've
seen your platform oh um my
parenting fails are um
[Music]
pretty extraordinary i mean flatting uh
oh there you go that's my best flat it's
quite good that one i think thank you
i'm very glad that you you showed that
one there are some other ones that you
could have shown that aren't
particularly good so there's been some
pretty bad ones those um nappy changes
you've had exploding nappies where you
haven't quite tidied it up properly um
i've had a few of those and then of
course you know just the fact that you
know
it's it's hard work um and uh
but it's great okay and what's your
proudest moment finally oh
unquestionably the birth of my two
children the marriage of my wife okay
thank you very much tom tugan hat um
many thanks be on the program this
morning thank you